hello and welcome to today's light
forecast drinking dial discovery with
formality my name is attractive and I'm
some outer Marcus's a specialist life
science and health plan lock agency i'll
be your order in for today's event we
are delighted to bring to this
educational web seminar presented by
elaborate and salsify advanced Bell
diagnostic advanced our diagnostic or
APD's is a leader in the field at the
letters apology its products and
services are based on company's
proprietary or innate coax technology
which is the first automated not address
primitive and fluorescence in switch
your hydration classes that is capable
of detecting and moisturizing foreign
labor market at single molecule
sensitivity you can find out more about
AP and our youth groups at www.att.com
so we have an important announcement
before ending in this webcast is
designed to be interactive and we do
encourage you to ask questions during
the event you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window will try to answer
as many questions as we can and if we
don't ask you a question during this
presentation what questions will be
answered by email afterwards you can
enlarge the flight window by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
quarters of light wonder if you do have
any technical problems viewing or
hearing whispers a patient please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problems through the green Q&A
button on the lower left ok so i would
now like to introduce today's speaker
dr. participative enter who is a
professor in the Department of Pathology
microbiology and
immunology at the school of veterans
that never fit you today but she
received her PhD from Harvard and her
Debbie Allen for the School of
Veterinary Medicine at UC Davis while
she continued her residency training and
has been on faculty since two thousand
ringgit Dr Pepper run field research
interest of focused for me
identification and characterization of
infectious diseases arriving from
intensely helped animals or animals of
the human animal interface she's going
to speak to us today about how her group
has discovered mobile viruses in our new
species and delete these viruses main
house with lead calamity so one else
owner of the dogs pesavento or her
presentation hi everyone this is a
Patricia Pesavento and I'm speaking with
you from the School of Veterinary
Medicine at UC Davis welcome to my
office as a veterinarian and a research
pathologist we have the unique
opportunity to investigate the natural
history of viral disease and we're
really focused here on comparative
medicine whether it's between humans and
animals or among the million species
because we feel like it can enlighten us
and enlighten you about viral potential
and mapping viruses to diseases and also
the range of host reactions that can be
that can happen relative to a disease so
we have a very strong one health program
here at Davis with a medical school and
the veterinary school and animal
sciences and our our focus on viral
discovery at least in my lab is in part
to extend our knowledge of the phylogeny
of viruses but it's very very exciting
for us especially to be able to
distinguish between viruses that persist
very quietly or inoculate innocuously in
our bodies over our lifetimes from those
that are really dangerous and what I'd
like to focus on today is given the very
strong history of viral discover
ever increasing capability we have for
discovering viruses how do we then
ensure ourselves that those viruses are
important indicate in case of disease so
just to extend the introduction that
Victoria has so graciously done and also
to thank a CD for inviting me and lab
roots for inviting me to do this I want
to explain what I do i think it's
relatively unique position where i'm in
a hospital that has many many cases of
animal individual animal problems but we
also do herd health care and aquarium
and zoo and we have a strong clinical
trials program as well the teaching
portion of my job is veterinary school
all the way to 4-h clubs and high
schools in the area and the last part
and the part that I'll be focusing on
today is the research and I come from a
background that cell biology and became
a pathologist and I'm very new to to
becoming a real virologist i'm sort of a
pseudo virologist so I'm really excited
about being able to bring this into into
this seminar so animal disease
surveillance in California isn't a whole
lot different than surveillance in other
states although it tends to be state
associate state associated they do share
the priority that the surveillance is
really there is an especially subsidized
to cover zone Oh Sees that is diseases
that can affect humans and so we have
strong programs that are able to
identify whether or not there's rabies
or influenza or other zoonotic diseases
California has a really wonderful system
of laboratories throughout the state
better the food safety and animal safety
laboratories and they're very very
strong part of our Animal Health Network
here in California and among our vet
school and these labs that we
across California we do a number of
different knee cropsey's surveillance
which i think is more is unique compared
to human medicine where autopsies or new
crop Caesar are more unusual so this is
a big part of our sampling pool for how
we track viruses and pathogens and
infectious diseases so to quickly get to
the strength of what our system is as a
pathologist we receive cases and we
estimate what diseases those animals
have based on the histology of those
tissues and this is a big part of my job
and we had an enormous the number of
cases that were enigmatic when I first
came on as faculty here we still have
always have an enormous number of cases
where we can't exactly estimate etiology
and I collaborated very early in my in
my faculty career here with dr. delve
art from UCSF who is an expert in viral
discovery and we have collaboratively
found a number of different viruses in
in animals novel viruses or viruses that
hadn't previously been recognized and
we're in the business of making sure
that the viruses that we find actually
linked back to the diseases that that I
saw basically in the first place in in
those in the original histology so none
of you should be surprised at all that
we're able to find viruses given the
techniques that we have today there's an
enormous capacity to discover viruses
and especially through novel methods of
deep sequencing there are a number of
labs and a number of releases of new
viruses in in this paper that's now just
a few years old a group of researchers
at Columbia University chose a single
species which was the Indian flying fox
pictured up in the right top corner of
the slide here and and did a very high
coverage sequencing method to Cal
and to describe an estimate all the
viruses in this single species and by
extrapolation in that paper what they
did is they try to estimate or
extrapolate to all mammals and estimated
that we have about 320,000 viruses out
there waiting to be discovered which
which pretty much means that if you pick
up any animal or any tissue from an
animal perhaps you have the chance of
discovering your own virus and I think
really that's nearly true these days and
almost and almost financially feasible
actually at this point but the really
important thing is to be able to say
that virus that you discovered is
important to the health of that species
and and that's what we're going to be
talking about so the fact that we can
find so many viruses might be able to
very very importantly identify what's
causing the disease and identifying the
virus and mapping it to the lesion will
really help inform us about how we could
treat or how well those animals or
individual animal is going to do I want
to briefly diverge to talk about another
repercussions but i think is very very
important about our ability to identify
viruses and bacteria so much more
efficiently these days and that is that
when when pathogens are symbiotic in
their relationship I think that we don't
right now have an easy way to to
identify that so let me give you a study
that was done now that was done now over
ten years ago that really blew my mind
one of them one of the things that
really encouraged me to look more deeply
at how to understand polymicrobial
infections' pep in yo and his group
published in avian diseases that when
they took a large group of turkeys and
infected them with 10 to the 10th colony
forming units of intera pathogenic
e.coli alone that those turkeys showed
no clinical signs at all even with a
with a heavy load of that
pathogenic e.coli by the same token they
could infect the turkeys with turkey
coronavirus and the turkey coronavirus
even though it would persist in the
turkeys cause no disease in those
animals but if you give a turkey
coronavirus at at day 0 let's say in
their timeline and then at any time
subsequent to that and they looked at
127 days after coronavirus infection you
can fully give those animals ten to the
six logs less so 10 to the fourth colony
forming units of enteropathogenic e.coli
and when you introduce those two
pathogens together half of the fluck
will die and more than that will be a
severely ill with that disease and what
this tells you is that coronavirus
infection alone if someone were just
studying this arm of the disease just
the coronavirus they wouldn't
potentially tell you know that's not an
important pathogen in Turkey's but we
have to be able to identify these two
together and recognize the symbiotic
relationship that they have and our our
sequencing methods are deep sequencing
our all of our new molecular methods and
coupled with the ability to to map that
dizzy that virus with that disease is
really a very powerful way to uncover
these polymicrobial infections' really
exciting stuff this is just a graphic
from eric dell wart in us in a review he
did on animal virus discovery and it's
just to say that the samples that we get
can be from just like in human medicine
can be from a whole number of different
places and people that are involved with
animal health from any of those regions
or have the ability to identify an
illness whether it's in an individual
animal or it's in an outbreak of animals
and let me go back just for a minute and
from that and from that identification
they could move into a variety of
methods that will review in order to
characterize a virus or a pathogen and
I'm focusing on by
is but a pathogen in that animal so the
different mechanisms of viral discovery
right now are very exciting and the
reason why we have so many new viruses
in our world traditional virologist
would often take a piece of tissue that
was an affected piece of tissue and put
it in cell culture and ask for whether
or not there were morphologic changes or
cell lysis in that culture and using
that fresh sample then if that virus was
cytolytic or if that virus caused cell
changes be able to recognize the virus
in that cell culture the limitations to
that the power and that is very strong
the limitations to that are obvious
which is that many viruses most viruses
don't cause morphological changes in
cell culture and so we can look at
viruses in a very nicely very nice
section by electron microscopy these
other mechanisms of viral discovery are
less or require less knowledge about the
tissue in the first place in other words
we can do micro arrays degenerate pcr
and deep sequencing by just retrieving
the nucleic acids from even a
formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded section
the micro ran the degenerate pcr
strategy is definitely required and
that's why these are starred here
definitely requires some a priori
knowledge of the sequences of the virus
but depending on how deep a deep
sequencing technique is this particular
method metagenomic method of discovering
viruses is less biased you basically
don't really have to know what virus is
in there in order to ask that question
so these are very powerful ways and many
people couple these ways and do more
than one when they're working so this
this particular focus on finding viruses
is has been really very powerful and has
been growing quite rapidly what I want
to spend the rest of the time I'm here
talking about is our ability to
associate the viruses that we find with
disease or our ability to
and not you know find figure out which
of tissues and things are being the
virus is living in and this is really
much trickier and I think that this is
the real the real front and excitement
and novel thing and viral discovery is
your ability to associate that with a
disease the power that's in this is
really remarkable so Disease Association
again we have some more traditional
traditional virological methods here
like electron microscopy and then we
have some that are more better have our
new or there are new methods and more
sensitive methods that are being
developed one of which we're going to
talk about today in particular I'll be
focusing on in situ hybridization and I
want to make sure you understand why my
lab is focused on in situ hybridization
we're very fond of electron microscopy
we're pathologists we love morphology
that specimen has to be really perfect
and the virus has to be quite abundant
to be there and in terms of pcr and
serology and i'll move to the strengths
and limitations of these other of these
systems that I've just listed in terms
of serology you really need to
prospectively find blood from the
affected animals and then also have the
pathogen or a protein express from that
pathogen in order to ask the question
about whether or not an animal has been
exposed and exposure doesn't necessarily
show significance but these
epidemiologic studies are very powerful
and showing the importance of the
pathogen PCR intensely sensitive and
lots and lots of studies on viruses and
tissues can demonstrate can demonstrate
the association but when we take a piece
of skin for example and grind it up and
then asked by pcr we really are unable
in that in that essay in a pcr-based
molecular assay to know which cell is a
target and also whether or not that is
either a contaminant for example of the
skin surface or actually is present in
the tissue and immunohistochemistry
which can map a pathogen to a tissue is
a very strong technique but generating
an antibody is not a true
Oh thing so i said i was going to focus
on in situ hybridization and i will with
two examples from here on out what you
need to start with an in situ
hybridization is what we already have in
hand from our viral discovery which is
the sequence of the pathogen so given
the sequence of the pathogen and the
tissue whether it's embedded fresh or a
fresh frozen example or embedded
paraffin example in situ hybridization
is a very very effective way of mapping
disease 22 with causality so my first
example then is on one that presented to
us as a single crossbred steer and that
was one with neurologic disease these
are a great concern to us as you can
imagine things that we have to rule out
in the diagnostic lab would be mad cow
disease would be a really important one
rabies another important one Listeria an
important zone otic pathogen and so our
neurologic cattle are ones we pay great
attention to both in our food chain and
in our individual animal health and we
had a cow that came to us with with
neurologic signs and we were able to
very very quickly rule out all of the
pathogens and potential ideologies that
you can see listed on your slide right
now but a variety of different assays
where where that left us was with what
we diagnosed this cow with was an
inflammatory and sefa lightest of
unknown origin that was likely to be
viral now we don't want to be stuck
there and so we immediately moved into
our metagenomics deep sequencing scheme
and were able to identify from brain
tissue from this affected steer an astro
virus that was very very similar to
other members of the family which are
highly divergent of the men Astro about
his family and and we were able to take
this virus and our immediate questions
were I think what you
no are very obvious which is that Astro
viruses are present in a whole wide
variety of mammals and birds and other
animals there are hundreds of thousands
of them that have been described and
most of them the large majority of them
are associated with enteric disease so
we were left with knowing that we had a
cow that was neurologic tissue from
which we were able to derive an astral
virus but not knowing whether or not
that usually in terra castro virus was
associated with neurologic disease in
this cow so we doing a phylogenetic
analysis was able to give us some clues
and we were very surprised that our
bovine Astro virus which is red dotted
here no matter whether we what one of
the portions of the genome we analyzed
mount very close to a cluster or
clustered very close to human Astro
viruses that had been identified in
neurologic disease as well as a mink
Astro virus that had been identified in
cases of neurologic disease so we were
very excited by that and what we did is
we moved immediately then into a
retrospective survey where we took 32
cases of bovine encephalitis where we
hadn't figured out an ideology and we
took the tissue from those and we first
did pcr on that series and we're only
able to identify two other cases where
we could amplify bovine Astro virus
neural s1 and moved there immediately
into in situ hybridization I'm going to
tell you the punch line right here is
that we were able to the punch line is
that that pcr amplification strategy
missed a half a dozen of the cases that
were also in this 32 case retrospective
because the in situ hybridization that
we did using the RNA scope was more
sensitive and I thought that was a
really remarkable and powerful way to
demonstrate the using combined methods
of discovery so let me go into what we
what exactly we did because I was new to
in situ hybridization
I use two different strategies for this
study I designed an oligomer pro that
was directly labeled it was a 28 murkrow
and recognized the open reading frame of
bovine Astro virus and and I'll point
out that this this method this in situ
hybridization method is actually able to
is actually able to map to two different
for example if we had two different
species of RNA and we wanted to identify
cell type for now what we wanted to know
is whether or not the virus was in
certain cells but the power of the probe
was going to go beyond that and did go
beyond that in our studies and so we we
designed an RNA scope to compare the
oligomer to and i'll briefly talk about
this technology this is a relatively new
novel technology and has an innovative
departure from traditional oligomer in
situ hybridization even full labeled
viral in situ hybridization which I've
done on several occasions but has some
or has had in my hand some background
problems and the technology and brief is
to take about a kilobase region of the
virus and it doesn't have to be
contiguous and design 20 probe pairs and
this is really vital 20 pairs that sit
next to each other across the region
that target the genome and by a signal
amplification cascade you will get up
you will get an amplification of your of
your viral sequence if and only if a
pair of adjacent probes hybridize so the
techniques becomes very sensitive and
very specific at the same time because 3
prepares have to hybridize together in
order to see the quantitative deposit of
the chromogen in that on that slide and
so we have since this time used RNA
scope bhishan eight viral projects all
of them successful and this is a non
radioisotope
that's semi-quantitative for viral load
which is also extremely helpful in
causality and so that's a i want to i
want to show you why i'm focusing on RNA
scope from the Advanced Cell diagnostics
and that is that I compared them
directly in two cases the one here is
the bovine Astro virus that I'll show
you and that by that method we did see
scattered neurons that had some labeled
probe and I'll compare that now to the
RNA scope in the same slide actually so
what you can see on this slide in the
region of the brain stem of the cow is
that a number of different neurons are
visible here some of them visible with
some gray spot or dust in them which is
our hybridization it is a believable
hybridization and it does tell us that
the neurons are the target it wasn't but
was much more exciting for us to look at
the same region by RNA scope and
identify not just the target neurons and
another about seventy percent of neurons
that we hadn't identified with an
oligomer but also the fact that then
that the virus was present within the
extensions the axons and dendrites of
the neurons as well so we could really
in this way and I'll show you a region
the cerebellum to RI is a pathologist
was unaffected there were some neurons
that were equivocal II were equivocal II
undergoing necrosis but as you can see
really very little inflammation
associated with us if we use the the in
situ hybridization method not only are
we seeing many of these cells affected
we see the extension into the molecular
layer of their dendritic processes which
is really exciting for me as a
morphology and it helps give us an idea
last is this is a ganglion as well the
cow was a toxic we were really
interested in the spinal cord which is
affected and what you see in this
picture there are a few neurons here
that are undergoing necrosis and those
neurons are full of virus with very very
little background in unaffected neurons
as in this case so really convincing and
enables us to do
multiple very powerful things for one we
could we could map that disease we could
with great confidence say that this
virus is in the correct cells to map to
the clinical presentation of this animal
and to be causative for this particular
encephalitis that was really the most
important thing that happened in this
study but above and beyond that as we
progress with our understanding of this
disease is that we could map the actual
distribution of the lesions because of
the sensitive method of it and we could
also be able to make some headway into
the pathogenesis specifically how that
virus gets into the brain and how it
causes neuronal necrosis very very
exciting work so I'm going to move to
our next our next example that I will
talk about here and introduce that by
saying that viral oncogenesis is
extremely important in human medicine as
and is becoming as we're understanding
it more effectively is becoming very
important in veterinary medicine as well
so fully sixteen to twenty percent
depending on who you quote of human
counselors can be attributed to either
bacteria or a viral pathogen so there
are very important they're very
important impact on the global view of
the global burden of cancer in our human
population and a lot of these have been
studied for a very long time cancer and
domestic and free-ranging animals much
less is known about about cancer in our
free ranging animals and we really have
no clue at all which pathogens are
contributing to cancer if they are but
I'd like to point out from a sort of a
one health perspective and a
veterinarian point of view that we're
creating humans are creating really
rapidly changing interfaces between
animals and humans and for example in in
re where we have very intensive housing
of animals in our agriculture if you
look at the history of the planet
agriculture and
dairies and things that where where
where our animal shelters like small
animal shelters very very very new in
our world extremely new in our world and
we're creating those as well because of
our population increases the interface
between humans and animals is quite
intense and our relationship with
animals has been changing over time and
is really pretty remarkably intimate and
so we have these populations of pets
where we've created a immune diversity
and immune bottlenecking if you will and
then by our imposition on the
environment we've also created wildlife
species that have very very low
diversity and susceptibility or
immunosuppression and might be more
susceptible to viruses than they were
previously so cancer in wildlife if you
had asked me honestly if you had asked
me 10 years ago even whether or not
cancer was a really important cause of
death in our wildlife populations I
would probably have said not so much and
the reason I would say that is because
they faced so many other very difficult
things it's very hard to be a wild
animal but I do think that that within
the last about five years what we're
seeing and what we've recognized is that
there are at least eight species now
that are threatened to endangerment that
are threatened to extinction because of
cancer and and that's a real new
phenomenon so we're really needing to
pay more attention to this to the viral
and the changing face of our wildlife
and humans own together so let me talk
about this really interesting story that
we're working on it's about the
relationship of a polyomavirus with
brain tumors and raccoons and
polyomavirus is used to be actually in
the same family as papillomavirus so the
cause of cervical cancer and now has
been split off obviously into into its
own
place and these are known to be
associated or there is a there are
species of polyomavirus that are known
to be associated with cancer and humans
and we'll talk a little bit about that
as well so here we are in davis pretty
much central in california and like
anywhere else that has suburbia we have
a good deal of raccoons that live in
intimate association with us they they
share our homes and our yards they eat
the same food we do just a little bit
later and so we're really very very much
involved they're very very much around
us they're very very successful as a
matter of fact if you take in suburbia
the equivalent of a city block the
number of raccoons that can live in that
region and that's because they're
supported by our our waste and etc is
about 55 you won't always see them but
they're there and and really quite
successful and non endangered the
raccoons share that interface that
region with a lot of other or what
welcome me so predators so mid-sized
animals including foxes opossums and
skunks our dogs and cats for sure and
here in California also badgers and some
other and definitely quite a few rodent
species and we have a very unique
opportunity at UC Davis to be involved
and to be in communication with wildlife
rescue services in in the bay area that
have been very very on it very very
tuned in to any diseases that are coming
through the wildlife population and we
have the Fish and Wildlife Services here
also extremely vigilant about changes
and they are the ones who recognized
that raccoons were coming in with
diseases with a disease different than
they had recognized before so what they
saw was neurologic disease that wasn't
December which is our typical thing and
and they brought those raccoons into the
diagnostic lab here and into the bmth
and said what's going on and in now to
get to the punch line
in about 200 raccoons that we have
necropsy did in the last few years fully
twelve percent of those raccoons have
had a brain tumor in the exact same
location of their brain and your
olfactory tract and that's remarkable
raccoons live about two or three years
in the wild and tumors are very very
unusual and raccoons and here we're
seeing twelve percent of the population
not just present with cancer represent
with the same cancer so we found that we
found that really intriguing this
happened in a short period of time
because we could look at the hundreds of
raccoons we had necropsy before that
time and know that there was no brain
cancer before that time and moreover we
could ask across the nation hey have any
of you who veterinary pathologist seen
brain tumors and raccoons and at least
by word of mouth we hadn't seen them and
so this was a relatively geographically
isolated incident as well so really
persuaded us to move on and use a
degenerate primer strategy to ask what
we started with which was whether or not
herpes virus or a polyomavirus was
associated with that cancer and
oncogenic viruses which many of which
are listed here really share the the the
characteristic that they're persistent
viruses and animals sometimes lasting
over your entire lifetime and it makes
it very very tricky to know if we find
one of these viruses whether or not it's
actually causal through cancer so we did
find a virus in the tumor tissue of the
raccoon that we dubbed raccoon
polyomavirus it looks very much like
sv40 which is the canonical virus of
this family and that virus was
associated with absolute has been
associated with a hundred percent of the
neuroglial tumors which is 20 at this
time that we saw and there was an high
copy number so that's a really enormous
number they remain to just on the west
coast and they're all within this exact
same anatomic location that you can see
here really interesting story so dr.
molly church wanted to ask our first
question question was
it the case that this virus is only on
the west coast and the results that she
had from creating this lovely Eliza that
was able for us to identify exposure to
raccoon polyomavirus is that like human
polyomavirus Rock polyomavirus is all
over the United States so she got
serologic collections from a number of
different states and showed that the
exposure was anywhere from five percent
to seventy percent very high in
California and in Washington the
exposure rate and lower in some states
but we also had East Coast states with
high exposure so it wasn't just the case
that the virus was in the west coast so
the question that we were left with was
whether or not raccoon polyomavirus was
causing the brain tumor or whether it
was just incidentally there and a
persistent virus so one of the things we
looked at very quickly was whether or
not the oncogenic protein for
polyomavirus which is the t antigen was
actually there in the tumors and we did
this two different ways the first way
I'm showing you here which is by
transcriptome analysis that the t
antigen was a hot in high was in high
copy number in those viruses and that
the structural proteins of that virus
were in very low copy new copy number in
that virus and what that told us was
that there was active transcription we
had no idea whether or not it was in the
tumor cells or whether it was in the
surrounding tissue so the next thing
that we did then was to look at the
tumors directly to ask whether or not
the viral transcript for large t antigen
remember that's the oncogenic protein or
the ankh agendas that transcript for the
oncogenic protein the protein that we
know is transformative was in the tumor
and here's the the hematoxylin and eosin
stain of one of the tumors in the
raccoon cross section of the tumor and
this is the tumor in the frontal lobes
of that raccoon where it exists and when
we used RNA scope ish for RAC pyv then
we saw that at least
fifty percent of the population and up
to a hundred percent of the population
was positive for LT or the presence of
that transcript was undetectable and in
high copy number within two months this
is another case where I used a all ago
probe and in that case we actually were
unable to detect the virus within the
tumor so another very persuasive a bid
for using a sensitive and specific
longer probe for your itch technique
especially one with this amplification
capability we made a xeno transplant
model of this tumor by taking a primary
cell culture and this is Kevin Willard
and Molly church Kevin Willard is a
neuro pathologist who is a collaborator
of mine and he and tears of raw stuff
and Molly Church created the xeno
transplant model which successfully
recapitulated the tumor within the mouse
and what we saw again by in situ
hybridization by the RNA scope method
was that that tumor in the mouse was
very similar to the one that we were
seeing in the raccoon we have tissue
culture as well or we have cells that
have been cultured out of the primary
and the secondary tumors or the xeno
transplant tumors and we're looking
forward to doing tissue culture RNA in
situ as well to ask about the expression
within within those two within those
cells I want to show you another very
persuasive picture visa V causality of
this this animal had the animal that
you're looking at here you're looking at
the liver of an animal where that brain
tumor was metastatic and so the normal
liver tissue is up here and library oh
and is an affiliate or pink in the top
of the slide and the tumor is the round
outlined lower right or corner right
population and again by the RNA scope
method the mothership tumor or the brain
tumor
had fifty percent of the cells
expressing the oncogenic protein large t
antigen and in the case of the
metastases that were in the liver the
adrenal gland and the lung of this
animal a hundred percent of those cells
had this oncogenic protein oncogenic on
transcript within the nuclei again very
very important to us in terms of proving
that this particular virus is causal or
necessary for the propagation of that
tumor so another thing that dr. Church
worked on is and this was one of the
most exciting parts that were really
focusing on right now is that that virus
was not only present in high copy number
in the tumor but animals that had the
tumor and animals that didn't have the
tumor had other tissues with a lower
copy number by pcr of the virus so that
included the kidney the intestinal tract
bone marrow salivary gland a number of
different tissues very common in
polyomavirus is not something that we
were surprised at but very difficult to
study because the copy number reflects
the fact that raccoon polyomavirus is
persistent and only present in a few
cells like one here and one there and
hasn't been studied very well at all in
human medicine because it's difficult to
obtain the tissues to study that and so
i will leave you all with the very
interesting result that when we looked
in the kidneys of these animals and we
saw some damage to kidney tubules so
you're looking at the cortex of the
kidney of a raccoon that was shedding
this virus and these are renal tubules
that you'll see in cross-section here
and one of those tubules in the center
is under growing undergoing necrosis or
undergo the cells are actually lysine
and sloughing off into the center of the
tubulin you can see that by this carry
erected debris that's in the center and
in a serial section of this exact same
part slide what you can see again by the
by
method is that individual cell nuclei
with in that tube you'll are cannot
contain that polyomavirus and that's
absent from the unaffected tissue
surrounding it and it was very
remarkable to me that I could map the
the minor damage within the kidney in
this normal animal that didn't have any
overt clinical kidney disease that I
could map a slowly degenerative process
in an animal so really very exciting
we're in a place now with because of the
proof of causality or in a place now
where we can take the cells that we know
are the targets of infection through the
ish studies and we can actually grow
those cells and now look to and infect
those cells and study infection of those
cells and try to understand whether or
not me when we're producing virus try to
understand the difference between this
virus getting into a stem cell in the
brain and causing a tumor versus getting
into a kidney and just very insidiously
causing minor damage to the kidney and
lasting for the lifetime of being so
we're very very excited about one of
these are going and I think I'll leave
that with questions and and back to our
our host our hosts and see if any of you
all have anything that you want to add
oh well thank you very much ready for
that really really interesting
presentation we are going to go question
in just a minute but I just want to let
you know it in and
or two we're going to be filling out a
couple of poles which would be really
great if you guys could process it is
just a couple of years no questions and
answers so just before we do get started
on the question answer session I would
like to remind right how to submit
questions so you can submit questions by
typing as any Q&A box which can be found
by clicking on green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation good and
what the gamin will try to answer as
many questions as a can and if we don't
get around to doing it here and now you
will be email afterwards and get those
answers for you so it is were pretty in
your questions we work we laughed a
little okay just give time for those
false second and give you guys time for
any questions okay so first question and
Penny and you show some examples of
sequential hematoxylin and input your
home invasion did you try to combine
both methods all things life so um hey
Thank You Victor for the question so
absolutely we have used on the RNA scope
primarily at this point for detecting
virus just in tissues but our lab is
really looking forward to doing double
methods on the same slide certainly
counter stained with hematoxylin and
eosin is very possible on the same slide
so the technology remarkably preserves
the tissue integrity even to this to a
cell level I've never had any trouble
identifying cell type to the to the to
the degree that i can do it for example
with H&E on a regular slide in addition
to that there is the possibility of
combining immunohistochemistry technique
with in situ techniques in order to
specifically identify this target cell
infection and i see i can actually
there's another question that's come up
on this question and answer session from
Omar Vieira that says did you see any
other virus such as CDV or canine
distemper virus in raccoons affected by
polyomavirus and that's a really good
question Omar is insightful in that he
recognizes I think that um usually
polyomavirus 'as when they are oncogenic
are affecting people that are
immunosuppressed and canine distemper
virus is highly immunosuppressive and
endemic in our raccoon population I can
only tell you Omar that that these
animals were probably exposed to canine
distort were exposed to canine distemper
virus that is entirely possible but we
they didn't have any active canine
distemper virus at the time that they
had the tumor in other words we couldn't
see any canine distemper virus at all we
couldn't see any canine distemper virus
at all within the brain at that time
that doesn't mean that they didn't have
it when they were younger and get over
it and have some bout of
immunosuppression but as far as we could
tell these animals were replete in terms
of their T cell population b cell
population and did not appear
histologically to be immunosuppressed
there's another question that I see up
here Victoria that that's tagged it says
do you think that RNA scope could lead
to accurate identification of diseases
with less material for instance and I
don't see anything after hold on I don't
see anything after for instance but with
less material absolutely on there are a
number of different publications that
look at RNA scope in individual cells
for example in smooth em like individual
single cells cytology as possible as a
Ekadasi anatomic pathologist I always go
for more tissue as you know we always
ask for as much as we can look at but
we've done needle biopsies we've done
very tiny biopsies as well a third
question here says does rack Paul why
polyomavirus infect other Anna
ah so we know that the host for raccoon
polyomavirus based on Molly's serologic
studies is the raccoon in other words we
know that they can be infected and very
mech we don't know whether or not it's
possible that this virus recently jumped
from another animal or is present in
other animals and that's a question is a
really insightful question because it's
something we're very interested in
looking for we'll probably tackle that
by asking whether or not animals have
been exposed and then moving on to
identifying a virus in those tissues I
have a question here from Roger Rennie
from talks path consulting and Roger
asks are there CNS signs a raccoon
polyomavirus infection distinct from
other viral diseases well so are N
equals 20 on this Roger and again the
reason that these very very astute
wildlife biologists and rehabbers were
able to identify this this raccoon
polyomavirus was or the the tumors
anyway was that they had raccoons in
that were not systemically ill viral
diseases usually cause fever and in a
case of distemper virus runny nose and
and and lethargy etc the raccoons that
were coming in were older dasol walking
around in circles and you could pick
them up and that is not common for a
record raccoons usually um raccoons
usually will want to kill you if they're
normal and in good shape and these
raccoons were really very unaware of
what was going on around them and most
of them progressed to being comatose
very quickly after being picked up by
these rehab facilities I will state
because it's very important to make the
clarification but the population of
raccoons that we look at as anatomic
pathologist is a very perverted one any
raccoon that's picked up by that's
picked up by the public or my rehabbers
is by definition going to be sick or
neurologic and so we've already skewed
our population very severely by looking
at those that we do okay um
RNA scope work on paraffin accessions
absolutely in fact it requires on the
RNA scope work that I'm doing with the
dab method works on embedded paraffin
sections and that's what all the
pictures that you saw were on
paraffin-embedded wax embedded tissue
I've done blocks back now 20 years
without any problem at all or loss of
integrity of the signal for viruses Gary
elsasser from fugo says I've been
tracking sv40 JC BK and especially CMV
around human cancers and it says you
mentioned that polyomavirus being
similar to I cannot see the rest of this
so I'm going to ask full question of
white blocks below got you thank you don
have you come across other viruses and
animal leading to tumors particularly
brain tumors so not brain tumors Gary
but papillomaviruses is undergoing a
great epiphany in veterinary medicine
some of the work that I didn't show you
today demonstrates some point papilloma
virus associated with genital tumors and
horses and also there are people that
are working on papillomavirus in dogs
and in and fibro papillomas and in cows
as well and horses so um so yes we're
starting to look at other types um
there's a question here from Utrecht
University from grown what is the
detection limit of RNA scope so the
published detection limit of RNA scope
and the company has advanced all
diagnostics has done a good amount of
work on this is even up to a single
virus in a Cell I think that that's
going to I think that that's going to
depend a little bit on an expression and
probe and it's the RNA expression or the
mRNA expression how the virus is
replicated etc the examples I gave you
today were one was an RNA virus a
single-stranded positive sense RNA virus
which was bovine Astro virus and of
course the probe that we chose
complemented
probe that we chose in that case
complemented the genome and the second
example I gave you which is the
polyomavirus is a double-stranded DNA
virus and in that case we were looking
at both genome and message or RNA so
understand that there's compared to mrna
copies of mrna of how genes that the
host is the host is I'm expressing
looking at viruses you have to look at
it with a little bit of a different view
which is you have to understand whether
or not you're looking at viral genome
copy number or expression of that genome
or both and I've got another question
here that asks to discuss the homology
level between rack pyv or raccoon
polyomavirus and sv40 the polyomavirus
a--'s are really interesting family and
like papilloma viruses they have been
evolving and living on our bodies since
basically since the out of africa
migration of humans mammals etc so the
sharing of sequence homology overall is
about fifty percent at the closest with
the closest known human polyomavirus
which is Merkel cell polyomavirus now i
will say that i've done some work with
papillomavirus and when i used probes to
bovine papillomavirus 12 and I looked
and I looked at a wart in a cow that was
caused by bovine papillomavirus for the
difference in those sequences was twenty
percent and the RNA scope is
distinguished very clearly between the
lesions that were caused by bpv 1 and 2
which are highly homologous and bpn
lesions that were caused by bpv for
which it didn't recognize without a
specific bpv for probe so this is a very
specific way of looking and obviously
you look at the identity from what I
from what I've been from my
understanding any time you fall off
sequence identity over ten percent
you're going to stop seeing
that that organization and I think that
we're going to close that but I do want
to say it's been really fun to talk with
you all and all of your definitely all
of your questions will be answered by
email by either me or representatives
from a CD if they're technical questions
and I've really enjoyed the questions
and all the people have been able to
talk to you so far thank you very much
patty for that great presentation and
really wonderful I would also just like
to thank Brittany a sponsor and I'm
self-diagnostics for making today's
educational web press possible just to
let you know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand during the
six months of United States you will
receive an email from Lavery's over to
me when webcast is available for replay
and we didn't like you to forward that
an absolute to your colleagues you made
mr. very large event so just my name
into paint everybody again for joining
us dr. patricia presento amounts of
diagnostic an elaborate thank you for
joining us and see you next time good
night